hey this is preshaw Walker here's a
multiple part interview question
you have wooden blocks numbered one two
and three and another set of wooden
blocks also numbered one two and three
you need to arrange the six blocks in a
row according to the following rule
you need to place the two blocks that
are numbered one with exactly one block
between them
you also need to place the two blocks
that are number two with exactly two
blocks between them
finally you need to place the two blocks
that are number three with exactly three
blocks between them
so that's the first challenge
how can you arrange the six blocks in a
row according to that rule
now let's get to the next challenge
let's add two blocks that are numbered
four
you also need the two blocks that are
numbered four to be placed with exactly
four blocks between them
so the Second Challenge can you arrange
these eight blocks in a row according to
the same rule
now let's go one more step let's add two
blocks that are numbered five you also
need the two blocks that are numbered
five to be placed with exactly five
blocks between them
now before you solve this challenge
you actually need to prove the following
that it's impossible to make an
arrangement of these ten blocks
according to that rule
so that's the interview question
by way of History this problem
originated in 1958 when C Dudley
Langford was noticing his child play
with colored number blocks and he just
happened to notice that for certain
Arrangements there was one block between
the ones two blocks between the twos and
three blocks between the threes
this became generalized into the
following mathematical problem
imagine you have the numbers one one two
two and so on up to n n
you need to arrange the numbers in a
permutation such that there is one digit
between the ones two digits between the
twos and so on up to n digits between
the ends such a sequence of numbers is
known as a Langford pairing
so the first question
for which values of n is this impossible
in other words what are the necessary
conditions so there is a solution for n
the second part for which values of n is
there a solution
what is the sufficient condition so that
there is a solution for n
I will end the video with an open or
unsolved question when there is a
solution how many solutions are there
and it's an interesting thing that this
is unsolved for n greater than 30. so
with this setup in mind pause the video
if you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
let's start by solving the blocks that
are numbered 1 2 and 3. I really hope
you've attempted this problem because
it's a very fun puzzle to solve
so here's how I approached it I thought
about starting with the two blocks that
are number three
because you need to place them with
three blocks apart there are limited
positions to try
so one possibility is putting them in
positions two and six there are three
blocks between them
we can also shift it over one spot so we
have positions one and five
but that's it these are the only
positions you could try because you need
to have three blocks between them there
aren't too many places you can put them
now let's start with the two blocks that
are number two
you can't put it in positions two and
five because position five is already
taken so let's try positions three and
six there are two blocks between them
that only leaves two spaces for the two
blocks numbered one and this will be
positions that are correct there's
exactly one block between them
so we've come across a solution three
one two one three two
now you might have come up with another
solution
so imagine reading the numbers from left
to right three one two one three two
well you could of course read the
numbers from right to left two three one
two one three
so whenever you have a solution you
could reverse the numbers and you would
come up with another solution
so two three one two one three will of
course also be a solution
so this will have the blocks based in
exactly the right positions
so you could say these are two different
solutions but mathematicians like to say
this is actually one solution
so this is one solution up to reversal
of the numbers we'll keep that in mind
as we go through the solutions of the
other puzzles
so now let's solve the problem with the
numbers one two three and four
as before let's start out with the
largest pair of numbers which is four
so there aren't too many places to try
for the four so let's just try in the
first block and the sixth block
so there are four blocks between them
now we can just experiment and try the
two blocks number three we can put them
over here so there are three blocks
between them in order to leave spaces
for the two blocks numbered one there's
only one spot we can put the two blocks
that are number two so we try that and
finally we have two spots remaining and
the two blocks numbered one will exactly
fit here so we have a solution four one
three one two four three two
again this is one solution up to
reversal
to illustrate that let's imagine we take
the same numbers and we read them going
from the end so this will be two three
four two one three one four this is
another solution but really we'll just
say the first is the unique solution up
to reversal of the numbers
now if we have the blocks numbered one
to five we need to prove that it's
impossible to come up with the solution
so rather than trying all the different
possibilities we're going to
systematically attack this problem
so let's say we have one one two two
three three four four and five five
so we need to place these into ten
positions so let's number each position
as one two three four five six seven
eight nine and ten
what can we say about these positions
well consider the two blocks that are
numbered one
if one block is at position a the left
block then the other block will need to
have one space between it so it will be
at position a plus two
so the block at a plus one is exactly
between them
consider the two blocks that are number
two if the left block is at position B
then we need to have B plus one and B
plus two so then the right block will be
at B plus three
when we have three and three it will be
at position C and C plus four four and
four will be at positions D and D plus
five and five and five will be at
positions e and e plus six
so how does this help us
if we have a solution
then
the positions of these ten blocks a A
plus two and so on will exactly need to
be equal to the positions one to ten
so let's do some analysis on this
if this is the case then the sum of the
numbers on the left needs to exactly be
the sum of the numbers on the right
so what's the sum of the numbers on the
left
well we have two copies of a two copies
of B two copies of C two copies of D and
two copies of e so we have two a plus
two B plus two c plus two D plus two e
and then we need to add 2 3 4 5 and 6
for the offsets
now what's the sum on the right hand
side it's the sum of the numbers going
from 1 to 10. so there's the famous
formula n multiplied by n plus 1 all
over two so here n is equal to ten and
we have 10 multiplied by 11 all over 2.
so on the left hand side we can factor
out the 2 for all of the variables we
have 2 multiplied by the sum of a b c d
and e
then we need to add the numbers 2 3 4 5
and 6. notice this is the sum of the
numbers going from 1 to 6 minus one
so we will write this as 6 times 7
divided by 2 minus one
then the right hand side is equal to 55.
so we'll simplify the left hand side the
sum of those numbers is equal to 20 and
then we'll subtract 20 from both sides
so we have 2 multiplied by the sum of
the variables is equal to 35.
now let's analyze this equation
we have 2 multiplied by the sum of these
variables is equal to 35. but each of
these variables needs to be an integer
so the sum of the integers is an integer
and we have two times an integer is
equal to 35.
but 2 times an integer needs to be an
even number and 35 is an odd number so
this is impossible there is no way that
we can arrange the numbers because that
would lead to the contradiction that 2
times an integer is equal to 35
therefore no solution exists
we can now generalize this approach to
find the necessary condition for a
solution
so let's say we have blocks that are
numbered 1 1 up to nn
so if we have two blocks that are
numbered K we can put their positions as
the left block as a k and the right
block as a K plus K plus 1.
this will mean there are K blocks
between the two blocks numbered k
so if a solution exists we can consider
the positions of the blocks it'll be A1
then A1 Plus One Plus One and this will
go up to the last block of a n and a n
plus n Plus 1.
this needs to exactly be equal to the
position of the blocks which will be the
numbers from 1 to 2N
so we will sum the left hand side and
that needs to be equal to the sum on the
right hand side
for the sum on the left hand side we
have two of each variable A1 up to a n
so it'll be 2 multiplied by the sum of
these variables plus we have the sum of
the numbers going from 2 to n plus 1 for
the offsets
this will be equal to the sum of the
numbers going from 1 to 2N which will be
2N multiplied by 2N plus one all over 2.
let's simplify this equation
we need to calculate the sum of the
numbers going from 2 to n Plus 1. so we
can do the formula for the sum of the
numbers from 1 to n plus 1 and then
subtract 1. so this will be n plus 1
multiplied by n plus 2 all over 2 minus
1.
let's multiply both sides of the
equation by two
we have 4 multiplied by the sum of the
variables A1 to a n plus n plus 1
multiplied by n plus 2 minus 2 is equal
to two n multiplied by two n plus one
let's expand the binomials and then
collect like terms
so we have 4 multiplied by the sum of A1
to a n is equal to 3n squared minus n
let's analyze this equation
we'll divide both sides of the equation
by 4 so we have the sum of A1 to a n is
equal to 3n squared minus n all over 4.
since the left hand side is the sum of
integers it will be an integer
so the necessary condition is the right
hand side also needs to be an integer
that is 3n squared minus n must be
divisible by 4. so when does that happen
it'll be convenient to think modulo 4.
so there are four possibilities to
consider n is equivalent to 0 mod 4 1
mod 4 2 mod 4 or 3 mod 4. so we'll work
out each case
in the first case 3 times 0 squared
minus 0 is equivalent to 0 mod 4.
then we have 3 multiplied by 1 squared
minus one that's equivalent to two mod
four that's not evenly divisible by 4
that's the remainder of 2. if n is
equivalent to 2 mod 4 we have three
times two squared minus two that's
equivalent to ten which is equivalent to
2 mod 4. that's not evenly divisible by
four finally if n is equivalent to 3 mod
4 we have three multiplied by three
squared minus three which is equivalent
to 24 which is equivalent to 0 mod 4.
so we can see in the two middle cases if
n is equivalent to 1 or 2 mod 4
we will end up with two mod four which
is not evenly divisible by four
so to summarize this if n is equivalent
to one or two mod four it is impossible
there is no solution
so we just worked out n is equal to five
that is equivalent to one mod four we
showed there was no solution the same
thing will be true where n is equal to 6
because that will be equivalent to two
mod four on the other hand if n is
equivalent to 0 or 3 mod 4 then it's
possible that a solution may exist at
this point we can't say for sure that a
solution exists in order to do that we
proceed to the next part which is
showing a construction that a length for
pairing always exists it's going to be
quite complicated but let me just give a
flavor of the proof
this was first shown in 1959 by Roy
Davies and I came across wonderful
write-ups on the website of Susan Paul
and bamshi jungala
so we get started by defining a number X
it'll be equal to n over four if N is a
multiple of four or it will be n plus 1
divided by four if n is equivalent to 3
mod 4.
we can succinctly summarize these two
cases by saying X is equal to the
ceiling of n divided by four so you take
n divided by four and you round up
that'll summarize these two cases
once we have this number X we can
construct a sequence we Define four
numbers a b c and d as 2x minus one four
x minus two four x minus one and four x
we Define a sequence P to be all the odd
numbers in ascending order in the
interval 1 to a minus 1 inclusive
to find another sequence Q to be all the
even numbers in the interval 2 to a
minus 1 inclusive
Define r to be the odd numbers in the
interval a plus 2 to B minus 1 inclusive
and finally Define s to be the even
numbers in the interval a plus 1 to B
minus 1 inclusive finally to find R of a
sequence to be the reversal of the
sequence s
then Define the following sequence we
want the reversal of s the reversal of p
b p c s d the reversal of R the reversal
of q b a q c r a d this is for n is
equivalent to zero mod 4. we have
another sequence if n is equivalent to
three mod four this will be the reversal
of s the reversal of p b p c s a the
reversal of R the reversal of q b a q c
r so the two sequences are very similar
but there will be just some minor
differences the first sequence has this
number D which is not there in the
second sequence and in the second
sequence a replaces d
so let's just try one example to see how
this works
Let's Take N is equal to 12 which is a
multiple four it's equivalent to zero
mod four
so X will be equal to n divided by 4
which is equal to 3.
we can then Define a b c and d to be
equal to 5 10 11 and 12. we now come up
with the sequences P will be equal to 1
3 Q will be equal to two four R is equal
to 7 9 and S is equal to 6 8.
so we go through this sequence of
numbers and we get the following eight
six three one ten one three eleven six
eight twelve nine seven four two ten
five two four eleven seven nine five
twelve and amazingly this is a Langford
pairing you can actually check that the
two numbers one will have one spot
between them and so on all the way up to
the two numbers twelve will have twelve
numbers between them so this is an
absolutely amazing construction now to
be completely rigorous you have to check
that every single digit in this
construction actually does follow the
rule of the Langford pairing it's not
too hard to do so I'll leave that for
the excited reader to actually work out
for themselves or you can check the
proof that's Linked In the video
description
so now I just want to go over one more
point so how many solutions are there
for a particular n
so for n is equal to seven we know that
a solution exists but in fact 26
Solutions are possible up to a reversal
and here are all of them on the screen
so all of these sequences are Langford
pairings
so it's not just that if you have a
solution you're going to have exactly
one
you could have multiple Solutions so
when n is equal to 7 there are multiple
sequences that work
now in general this is a very difficult
problem to work out if you have n and
you need to know the number of solutions
well of course for some cases we know
that it's zero but in other cases it's
going to be a very large number
so these are the numbers that have been
worked out so the largest worked out
number is n is equal to 28. it's in a
very large number
we know that 29 and 30 will be zero now
what about 31 Nobody Knows the answer to
this this is unsolved so these large
cases actually can take weeks and months
to work out with various computers
actually cranking through the numbers
and it's very difficult because you're
dealing with possible computation errors
this is an absolutely fascinating
problem a mathematician was just looking
at his child play with wooden blocks he
came up with an interesting puzzle and
it's actually led to a problem that
still unsolved to this day
wow
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]